hey how are you all right welcome to
kiddie powers matchmaker
I hate tutorials shut the [ __ ] up oh my
god this is my character salad s got a
good rep look like [ __ ] all the
character looked like they are inbred
in this game for some reason so here we
are now we get to pick our client mm-hmm
who should I pick um Isla I'm a pizza
delivery driver I'm looking for a woman
well well well well well you swing your
whatever way you swing I will make your
ding-a-ling go ding-a-ling ever know
what I mean Hey she likes laptops and
animated gifts and ghost hunting what it
if you're from tumblr aren't you Jesus
Christ all right
she loves great eyes and ginger hair oh
my god gray eyes all right let's state
yes I'm sure
all right I really don't give a [ __ ]
where we're going or route 69 what
that's like the sexual position oh yeah
you must be my leg nice to meet ya this
place looks alright Jenny yeah it ain't
bad for a bit nosh yes nice ginger color
in it oh thank you very much
sell me hot wait no me I'm a [ __ ] Aaron
in it something hot with no meat she
wants macaroni and cheese very nice
choice great sounds lovely yeah I'm
starving for [ __ ] oh wait
alright I heard you like studying
chemistry
yeah flippin love studying chemistry no
one likes studying chemistry okay what
should I say will you go out with me can
I see you again let's just be friends
with you guys with me do you want to get
serious you won me over with your charm
ain't chat yeah we're in love ain't we
so is this how lesbians kiss quality
gameplay we did it really if you think
about it doesn't dating website benefit
from people not meeting other people
does don't they make a living out of
people dating more and more people it's
really if you find matches is kind of
irrelevant for them
I would like to have some spiciness yeah
I love spicy food I got I going to know
if my date is sweet and lovely even
priest why did she say those awful
things okay we got we got who did we got
we got all right chels
calm down come to [ __ ] down Chelsea
Chelsea you're gonna give me nightmares
Chelsea if you don't stop I'm gonna have
to call your mother did you just [ __ ]
your pants Chelsea she likes internet
memes handmade knickknacks and retro
peanuts
for [ __ ] sake another tumblr [ __ ] she
lived for brown eyes and black hair
she's romantic all right all right all
right let's get this tumblr girl their
lover of her life and a dangle Anil
let's make them go to jerking get it ken
told me to play this game all right and
it's too late for me to play something
else so we're gonna [ __ ] keep playing
this all right let's make these girls
scissor hi how are you Hannah yes I am
you must be Chelsea so fab to meet you
this is a nice place isn't it yeah it's
like rave reviews your brother's like
everything Thanks has been out as of you
say okay she likes something hot with no
meat I can make jokes too all right ah
not spicy how about stepping up I'm
sorry
she's going to the restroom what is she
doing at the restroom
okay did you get a boob job
what it wasn't her hair oh I mean I
really can't tell the difference
okay so we're lying to her that we love
her job come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on oh god oh god no
please no
yeah Jimmy come on wow that's super cool
I think they might be laying this is
possibly the worst date I ever been on
I'm sorry you're the one who went out to
color your hair blue during the day and
you're calling me a bad date you know
what [ __ ] she's she's dude you're too
good for her Chelsea Chelsea don't worry
Chelsea Chelsea calm down Chelsea
Chelsea don't do that lip thing
Chelsea I know don't you [ __ ] your pants
again Chelsea I've been meaning to come
here for like literally eons you were
there yesterday
a cold no meat this she wants coleslaw
and it's come become it has become
necessary that I had just many parents
okay
please remain here okay she changed her
hairstyle know what she do that are you
kidding me
wait where did she keep that [ __ ]
sweater okay here's the moment will they
go out me let's just be friends guess
all that I ain't got no luck man
do you love cranny crash
do you love anymore girls of course did
you of car everyone that's any mood